we always be Dallas I hate Philly it's
old its code why are they important to
anyone I'm kind of describing Bryan
right now now move it in here we got
some unfinished business
all right our teams arrivals today we're
gonna be rivals we're gonna compete in a
few competitions I'm gonna beat you in a
few comfortable being down by one is
something that Dallas fans are used to
right no dad that was the cheesesteak
weighing me down you had a cheesesteak
yeah went to Jim Jim's yeah sweet it out
what was the best everybody kept saying
Jim if you come to Philly you gotta have
a cheese stick oh yeah I already knew oh
that one man all you need is three point
three points is what winning looks like
I shoot win this you should I should we
really should yeah I feel no pressure
consistency you want to see the harm
yeah oh yeah that's the touch that's a
quarterback type you went for looks I
bet yeah sorry
so just worthy one three just don't hit
down the first one I'm gonna talk about
this I feel like I could hit it boom yes
right back to the - so you're so used to
hitting people in the chat it's the
pressure
I'm so low just the bullet point we're
gonna wind down a little bit bring it
back over here and talk some football
we're gonna make some pigs all right
let's do it
so the first game we're gonna be talking
about is gonna be Buffalo a New England
New England they have the goat that's
the reason why you got to go with the
goat my pigs gonna be New England as
well New York and Washington I think I'm
gonna lean a little bit closer a little
bit more to the Washington team just
because it's two teams that are the
giriboy in scene yeah I don't know my
stomach's telling me to go New York so
that's my thing
Green Bay in Minnesota I love
Minnesota's ability to run the football
and stop the run that's where I'm going
with the Minnesota team I'm gonna go
with Green Bay on this one the most
important game the big game
Dallas versus Philly of course I'm
picking the birds I'm going with my boys
I almost save the star in the side of my
head lettuce you do Iron Man well I had
a lot of fun today it's very nice
meeting you
Philadelphia is a beautiful place all
jokes aside shout out to here is
Philadelphia for having us out here we
got some unfinished business but it's
about to be set up
let's see during the game go Birds
[Music]